jean luc mélenchon explique ce qu'il
compte faire une fois élu président de
la république au delà de 12 millions
d'héritage je prends ton avant qu'il
n'en est pas à son coup d'essai en
matière fiscale et les surligneurs
relève régulièrement ses propositions
démesurée la mesure annoncée prendrait
la forme d'une loi modifiant le barème
des droits de succession ce barème est
relativement complexe car il tient
compte à la fois du montant de la
succession et durant de l'héritier par
rapport aux défunts les héritiers en
ligne directe sont les moins taxés alors
que les cousins éloignés peuvent être
imposées jusqu'à hauteur de 60 % de plus
ce barème ce calcul autour de cette
branche progressive la première exonérés
ou un autre et bras la plus haute dites
marginales imposé à 45 % au-delà de 1
million 800 mille euros d'héritage avec
sa proposition jean luc mélenchon
souhaite créer une 8ème tranche à 12
millions d'euros avec un taux
d'imposition de 100% et c'est là tout le
problème le conseil constitutionnel juge
depuis longtemps qu'au delà d'un certain
montant l'impôt serait confiscatoire est
contraire à la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen ce principe a été
plusieurs fois confirmé et notamment en
2012 lorsqu'il avait été question de
créer une tranche marginale 45% pour
l'impôt sur le revenu à partir de 150000
euros de revenus annuels
alors une question se pose à partir de
quel montant un impôt devient-il
confiscatoire
malheureusement répondre à cette
question est beaucoup plus difficile
qu'avant c'est une promesse électorale
inconstitutionnelle en effet le montant
d'1 1 pour 8 analysé au regard non
seulement de son taux mais aussi des
autres impôts pouvant s'appliquer à la
même matière imposable par exemple le
conseil constitutionnel a jugé
confiscatoire un taux de 77 %
d'imposition sur les stock options ou de
82% sur les plus values immobilières par
conséquent une réforme créant une
tranche de 100 % l'imposition serait
immanquablement jugé contraire à la
constitution
jean luc mélenchon persiste avec ses
nombreuses promesses fiscales
inconstitutionnelle un surnom lui paraît
donc tout trouvé confisqué à tort